you see your life whispers to you all
the time if you're paying attention from
the moment you open your eyes in the
morning until the moment you go to bed
at night it's just speaking to you and
really hearing those whispers is one of
the most integral pieces of the puzzle i
believe that's needed to put together
the bigger picture
of your best life now there might be a
message sent or meant for you that first
comes in a whisper that to you sounds
like
hmm
that's strange or hmm that seems odd i
didn't leave that door open but then if
that whisper isn't addressed the whisper
will become amplified getting louder and
louder until it suddenly becomes what i
call a big thump on your head and if
you're still not paying attention that
little nudge transforms into
a brick of a problem and then eventually
all of those ignored bricks that make up
the structure and stability of your life
come crashing down so
know this for sure life is whispering to
you all the time
then turns into a brick of a problem you
ignore that problem you get a brick wall
of crises so the key is learning to get
the whispers
before they turn into bricks
so
this has shown up most often in my life
through relationships bad relationships
when i was younger when someone has
shown me who they are in a whisper and i
keep hanging on until they do something
that's like a brick upside my head
so last year listen to this i toured for
wwe from january 4th to march 8th and
immediately after that last show i went
to the bahamas to take a week's break
and after two days i started feeling the
strong whisper just a feeling that maybe
i shouldn't be relaxing in foreign
waters and should get home
in case
our country went into some kind of
shutdown literally at three in the
morning that feeling came over me
that i need to leave i need to get home
so
i returned home on march 11th stayed in
lockdown for the next 321 days
and i've learned over the years to kind
of pay attention and heed what twists to
bring before it has to knock me upside
the head
so many things in life
like the pandemic are out of our control
but i do know that many things are in
our control
unless you choose to sleepwalk your way
through it so i ask you what is
whispering to you right now
some of you may have realized the life
you live before the pandemic no longer
actually serves you and that returning
to working in an office is not your next
best move or maybe you gained a deeper
appreciation for your family and friends
or alone time as we talked about last
week you might even have turned a
passion or hobby into a full-on business
but there are others who are just going
to
get right back to their routine without
heaving those whispers and understanding
what is really calling to you if there's
one message you take away from me today
it's to listen to the whispers
because you are in the driver's seat as
to where
they leave you
so for the 25 years that i did the oprah
show i would often get frustrated
because some guests who would come back
and they just weren't paying attention
to their life
but i realized too it's easier to
observe it it's often much easier to
observe someone else's situation more
clearly than your own so i encourage you
to take the time to observe and listen
become aware and learn to discern what
your head is saying versus what your
heart is saying and sometimes you may
follow a voice in your head that's not
your true calling and that's okay too
because you get as much from the losses
as you do from the winds
so i say
just keep
listening
being aware
of what is whispering to you now
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation top 10
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best oprah winfrey
and my take on her top 10 rules for
success enjoy
rule number two stand for something so
many people are worried about building a
brand i hear kids on social media
talking about their brand
and i used to really resent the word
when people would say to me oh you have
this brand because i never never even
thought about a brand i just thought
about day in and day out making the best
right choice for me but now i embrace it
because i recognize people see me as a
brand
but for me it's not a business it is a
question of what do you stand for
and i will say this you're nothing if
you're not the truth
so i have made
i've made a living
i've made a living i've made a life made
a fortune really it's fantastic
all good
[Music]
from being true to myself
and that's the if i could leave you with
any message today that is it
uh the biggest reward is not financial
benefits though it's really good you can
get a lot of great shoes
nothing wrong with great shoes
but those of you who have a lot of shoes
know that having great shoes and a
closet full of shoes or cars or houses
or square footage doesn't fill up your
life
it doesn't but living a life of
substance
can
substance through
your service your offering of your whole
self
and the baseline for how do you live a
life of substance is whatever is the
truth for you what do you stand for rule
number three be humane people may not
remember your every word
they may not remember all of your
actions but they certainly remember
how your words and your actions made
them feel
so let's leave here today
with the collective memory
of wanting to create enlightenment in
the world
let's leave here
knowing that we can give people the
sense
that they have been heard and respected
let's foster original thinking
and humane treatment
let's seek out the words we don't know
let's do away with the us and them i've
seen us and them create a whole lot of
problems but i've never seen it solve
one thing instead let's nourish our
artists let's offer the possibility of
something better
for all of us
because a new day is no longer on the
horizon
the new day is now rule number four
illuminate darkness if you can capture
the humanity of people
if you can just capture the humanity of
the people of the stories that you're
telling you then get that much closer to
your own humanity and you can confront
your bias and you can build your
credibility and hone your instincts and
compound your compassion
you can use your gifts that's what
you're really here to do
to illuminate
the darkness in our world
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five
serve all of you know the story of how
this great school came to be how the
stanfords lost their only child to
typhoid at the age of 15. they had every
right and they had every reason to turn
their backs against the world at that
time but instead they they channeled
their grief
and their pain into an act of grace
within a year of their son's death
they'd made the founding grant for this
great school
pledging to do for other people's
children what they were not able to do
for their own boy
the lesson here is clear and that is if
you're hurting you need to help somebody
else ease their hurt
if you're in pain help somebody else's
pain and when you're in a mess you get
yourself out of the mess helping
somebody out of theirs and in the
process you get to become a member of
what i call
the greatest fellowship of all the
sorority of compassion and the
fraternity of service
the stanfords had suffered the worst
thing any any
mom and dad can ever endure yet they
understood that helping others is the
way we help ourselves and this wisdom is
increasingly supported by scientific and
sociological research it's no longer
just woo-woo soft skills talk
there's actually a helper's high
a spiritual surge you gain from serving
others so if you want to feel good you
have to go out and do some good
but when you do good
i hope you strive for more than just the
good feeling that service provides
because i know this for sure that doing
good actually makes you better
so whatever field you choose
if you operate from the paradigm of
service
i know your life will have more value
and you will be happy
i was always happy doing my talk show
but that happiness reached a depth of
of
a fulfillment
of uh of joy
that i really can't describe to you a
measure
when i stopped just being on tv and
looking at tv as a job and decided to
use t television to use it and not have
it use me
to use it as a platform to serve my
viewers
that alone changed the trajectory of my
success
so i know this that whether you're an
actor
you offer your talent in the way that
most inspires art if you're an anatomist
you look at your your gift
as knowledge
and service to healing rule number six
overcome hysteria the problem is
everybody is meeting hysteria with more
hysteria
and then we just are all becoming
hysterical and it's getting worse
what i've learned all these years is
that we're not supposed to match it or
even get locked into resisting or
pushing against it we're supposed to see
this moment in time for what it is we're
supposed to see through it and then
transcend it
that is how you overcome asteria
and that is how you overcome
the sniping at one another the trolling
the mean-spirited partisanship on both
sides of the aisle the divisiveness the
injustices and the out and out hatred
you use it
use this moment
to encourage you to embolden you and to
literally
push you into the rising
of your life
and to borrow a phrase from my beloved
mentor maya angelou just like moons and
like sons with the certainty of tides
just like the hopes springing high
you will rise rule number seven have
compassion having compassion for other
people is at the top of that list
i would say commitment is at the top of
that list and also a spirit of
constructive engagement and by
compassion i don't just mean sympathy it
certainly isn't pity it's being present
and it's also
feeling with other beings you know
during the years of the oprah show i
interviewed over 37 000 people one on
one
so whenever i'm telling my girls
anything and they say ah they start
rolling their eyes like oh
i'm the only person you're going to talk
to talk to 37 000 people
so if i were you i would pay attention
but during all those years of talking to
over 37 000 people one on one
i could feel what they were feeling so
strongly sometimes it made me sick
literally
so i had to learn how to
feel how others were feeling feel with
others which
is which is what it means to be
compassionate to feel with others
without taking in all of their stuff
being compassionate means i feel
with
you
it is one of the greatest qualities in
the world to have if you're going to be
majoring in what it takes to be a great
human being i feel with you
means i not only am willing to walk in
your shoes
it means my heart beats with yours
it means i see myself in you it means
i
may not have shared that circumstance
but i know what heartbreak feels like i
know what pain feels like and all pain
is the same
it means
i can feel your will to want to do
better and be better and i feel and i am
with you in spite of everything that's
happened to you
i
feel your need to rise i want to help
you rise i want to rise with you rule
number eight be graceful dr king said
not everybody can be famous
and i don't know if everybody everybody
today
seems to want to be famous but fame is a
trip
people follow you to the bathroom
listen to your pee let's just
try to pee quietly it doesn't matter
they come out and say oh my god it's you
you peed
[Applause]
that's the fame trip so i don't know if
you want that
so
dr king said not everybody can be famous
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service
yet those of you who are history
scholars may know the rest of that
passage he said
you don't have to have a college degree
to serve
you don't have to make your subject and
verb agree to serve you don't have to
know about plato or aristotle to serve
you don't have to know einstein's theory
of relativity to serve you don't have to
know the second theory of thermodynamics
and physics to serve
you only need a heart full of grace and
a soul generated by love rule number
nine be truthful you make the choice
every day
every single day to exemplify honesty
because
the truth
let me tell you something about the
truth
the truth exonerates
[Music]
and it convicts
it disinfects
and it galvanizes the truth has always
been and will always be
our shield against corruption our shield
against greed and despair the truth is
our saving grace annual number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is let go letting go of energy
that's clouding your vision and holding
you back
it's a life practice that i learned long
ago that has freed me
so many ways it's a fact that holding
grudges against somebody who's done you
wrong
or
replaying revisiting hurtful situations
in your head over and over only weighs
you down and prevents you from being who
you're meant to be
right now because you're still
energetically holding on to the past the
energy that you put into constantly
rewinding to the resentment why did they
do that why did they say that to me i
didn't deserve to be treated that way
all of that only keeps you stuck
it will never change what happened
you gotta press stop
and reject the urge to keep replaying so
that you can then fast forward into the
now for yourself you know
a lot of people think
that holding on to things that
disempowered them
is going to somehow magically turn it
around
as i said in my message a couple weeks
ago about forgiveness
you have to release the notion give up
the hope that the past could have been
any different and you also must release
the idea that people would do what you
might do in any given instance this is a
big one i had to learn and relearn
before i actually got it expecting
people to do what you would do in a
situation only leads to your
disappointment not theirs they're going
on with their life so let people be who
they are and either you accept it or you
don't
not doing that keeps you stuck in a
circumstance that actually costs you
time cost you energy and i can guarantee
that oftentimes the person on the other
side of the bitterness you're holding on
to they're not even thinking about you
in fact they probably have just moved on
they certainly aren't obsessing the way
you are think of it like letting go of
any bad habit that just doesn't serve
your well-being not an easy task
taking the road to a more enlightened
healthy existence never is so
this is what i want to ask you to ask
yourself
why
am i holding on to this
how is this serving me
and really think about the answer
maybe it makes you feel validated maybe
it makes you feel righteous
or maybe
taking on the pain is your way of
recognizing the injustice so that even
though it won't be made right
it can at least not be forgotten
then i ask you again ask yourself
do you want to be right
or do you want peace
this was huge for me
the unfortunate fact is that having both
may not be possible
and also you may never get your moment
of righteousness so why wait for it
choose peace
what i know for sure
is that in this world
time is a moving on and it's our most
valuable commodity you can never get it
back
so staying in that loop playing it over
and over in your head of hurt only
amplifies your pain let it go
exhale make room in your heart for
something that is uplifting
surround yourself with people who want
the best for you you have the ability to
shift the dna of your spirit and control
how you perceive life so why not lighten
your load and let it go
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the good deed of the day
this is something new i believe that
you're able to serve and it feels so
good to do something nice for somebody
else so good deed of the day put down in
the comments one thing that you need
help with that you're working on you'd
love some support or guidance on and
then two go comment on somebody else's
comment and give them some love give
them some support give them some
encouragement maybe give them some
connections try to help them solve that
problem even if it's saying i believe in
you that one little bit of encouragement
can be the difference between somebody
quitting and continuing on so the good
deed of the day in the comments below
write down one thing that you need help
on that you're struggling with that
you're working on and then part two is
go give love to somebody else in the
comments too and let them know that you
believe in them as well
i
am committed to service
service through my work
service through my life's purpose
and if you make a commitment a conscious
intention to be committed to the work
that you do to the relationships that
you have
your life will unfold with such beauty
and grace through that commitment it
doesn't matter how far you might rise at
some point
you are bound to stumble because if
you're constantly doing what we do
raising the bar
if you're constantly pushing yourself
higher higher
the law of averages not to mention the
myth of icarus uh predicts that you will
at some point
fall
and when you do i want you to know this
remember this
there is no such thing as failure
failure is just life trying to move us
in another direction now when you're
down there in a hole it looks like
failure
so this past year i had to spoon feed
those words to myself
and when you're down in the hole when
that moment comes it's really okay to
feel bad for a little while
give yourself time to mourn what you
think you may have lost
but then
here's the key
learn from every mistake
because every
experience encounter and particularly
your mistakes are there to cheat you and
force you into being more of who you are
the greatest lesson i've learned
throughout my career came from maya
angelou actually
when i was you know first meeting her
and uh
after i'd known her for a while she said
baby you know
you need to know that when people show
you who they are
you believe them
the first time oh you know that lesson
too now
first time and uh your problem is it
takes you 29 times to see the same
lesson coming in a different skirt
wearing a different pair of pants so i
think that has been one of my
greatest wisdom teachings is to
assess
uh from people's behavior their actions
not just towards me but towards other
people
uh who they are and how they behave
because if people talk about other
people they'll talk about you so i think
in business and in personal
relationships that's also been my
greatest uh lesson the challenge of life
i have found is to build a resume
that doesn't simply tell a story
about what you want to be
but it's a story about who you want to
be
it's a resume that doesn't just tell a
story about what you want to accomplish
but why
a story that's not just a collection of
titles and and positions but a story
that's really
about
your purpose because when you inevitably
stumble
and find yourself stuck in a hole
that is the story that will get you out
what is your true calling
what is your dharma what is your purpose
the way to make movies is to do stuff
that you love because you know for 25
years i worked on the oprah show and
uh stephen will tell you that there were
nights that i came home and i
almost you know it's hard to even like
take off my clothes because i knew i was
going to be getting up four hours later
but i never really felt exhausted
like depl i never i felt exhausted but i
never felt depleted so do the work that
comes straight from
the soul of you from your background
from stories that you've grown up with
from stories that bring you passion from
stories that you uh not just yearn to
tell
but that if you don't tell them they
won't get told and when you when you are
operating you know the single
the single greatest uh wisdom i think
i've ever received other than
when people show you they are is that
the key to fulfillment success
happiness
contentment in life is when you align
your personality
with what your soul actually came to do
i believe everybody has a soul and has
you know their own personal
spiritual energy so when you can use
your personality to serve whatever that
thing is
you can't help but be successful so if
you do films that come from the interior
of your soul you do work you do art that
comes from the interior of you
it you cannot miss
it's only when you're doing stuff that
you think might make money you think it
may be
a hit or you think it may
bring you some level of attention or
success that isn't what does it i would
have to say that all of the great
wonderful experiences of my life that
have brought me to this moment have come
from working from the interior of myself
and so that's why it feels so authentic
because it
it actually is
so when you do that you'll win there
comes a point
and i'm really i'm really good at this
is at not holding on to what was
and being able to live in this present
moment you know i never was one of those
women who's afraid to tell your age or
you're trying to be something you're not
i mean i think
for everything there's a time and a
season
uh the bible is
completely right about that i think i
think um
and you know in your own self when it's
time to move from that my television
career began unexpectedly
uh as you heard this morning i was in
the miss fire prevention contest
that was when i was 16 years old in
nashville tennessee
and you had the requirement of having to
have red hair in order to win
up until the year that i entered so they
were doing the question and answer
period because i knew i wasn't going to
win in the swimsuit competition so
during the question and answer period
the question came why young lady what
would you like to be when you grow up
and by the time they got to me all the
good answers were gone
so
i had seen barbara walters on the today
show that morning so i answered
i would like to be a journalist
i would like to tell other people's
stories in a way that makes a difference
in their lives and the world
and as those words were coming out of my
mouth i went whoa this is pretty good
i would like to be a journalist i want
to make a difference
well i was on television by the time i
was 19 years old and in 1986 i launched
my own television show
with a relentless determination to
succeed at first i was nervous about the
competition and then i became my own
competition raising the bar every year
pushing pushing pushing myself as hard
as i knew sound familiar to anybody here
eventually we did make it to the top
and we stayed there for 25
years
the oprah winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21 years and i have to
tell you i became
pretty comfortable with that level of
success every single day to channel our
own inner jucindas
to exemplify the truth
and the respect
and the grace
that we actually wish for the world
we need to tell it as we're doing at
this conference we need to write it
we need to sing it we need to proclaim
it
we need to be it we need to be the truth
we have to be the respect we have to be
the fierceness the love that we want to
see
and when we do that mark my words a
change is already
coming i wake up in the morning what you
do and the first thing i say is thank
you
that's my first thing
even before i'm awake even before my
eyes are really fully open i i say thank
you i can feel the gratitude like i'm
still here i'm in a body thank you so
much i thank you for that and then i go
through the letting the dogs out the
whole you know brushing your teeth and
all that stuff and then i have either
silence or prayer or something that
acknowledges that i'm still here i do
not reach for that phone first that's
your problem you have no idea the power
of
noticing
another human being
and what it feels like when somebody
knows that they have been seen truly
seen by you
it is the greatest offering you can give
and all those years of the oprah show
the greatest lesson i learned was that
you know after every show
uh someone would say invariably in one
way or another um
how was that i'd finish an interview
with father who killed his twin
daughters i'd finish an interview with a
politician barack obama joe biden george
bush they beyonce they all say the same
thing
how was that
and so i started to see that there's
this common thread in our humanity
where everybody wants to know
how was that
did i do okay
did you hear me
and did what i say
mean something to you
so i would have to say that
recognizing that in other people has
helped me to become you know a person of
compassion a person of understanding a
person who can interview anybody about
ever anything because i know that if the
core of you is the same as core me you
just want to be heard let me ask all
this have you ever made a complete fool
of yourself over a celebrity
[Applause]
[Music]
i have i've never shared this story with
you but today i feel i have to let it
out it was 1973 or four i was uh 19 or
20. i can't quite remember but i was
working in nashville and i had this
obsession i mean obsession
with neil diamond
[Applause]
now
i would wake up
i would wake up in the morning playing
song song blue everybody and i would go
to bed to crackle and rosie and which is
not an easy thing to do in high school
because i could have lost my negro
membership card
you know there were not a lot of negroes
singing
crackling rosie but okay so i'm working
in television at this television station
and there was some kind of benefit and
neil diamond was there because he was
performing in town and so i'm in the
green room and i am by the time 1973 i'm
already uh anchor woman on tv and so i
walk into the green room and there he is
and so i say mr diamond would you like
some shrimp
[Applause]
and he said
and he says yes yes i'll take a shower
and he took her shrimp and i'm like
okay
and then he moved across the room and
then i followed him across the room
that's a big mistake that's the big
mistake people make so i follow him
across the room and so i'm like
would you like another shrimp
[Applause]
and he said
yeah i'll take i'll take a shrimp
he did and then i followed him again
so i'm just staring at him across the
room
and finally i walked up and he goes
enough already
enough already okay so that was my
real
diamond moment what i deeply believe is
not that do unto others as you would
have them do unto you
what you do is already done
that moment in the color purple where
she says everything you ever tried to do
to me
where whoopi says that i silly
everything you ever everything you even
try to do to me already done to you so
the law the third law of motion in
physics says that what you're putting
out is coming back
all the time regardless of whether you
know it or acknowledge it or not i know
you all understand better than most that
real progress requires
authentic
an authentic way of being
honesty and above all empathy
i have to say
that the single most important lesson i
learned in 25 years talking every single
day to people
was that there is a common denominator
in our human experience
most of us
i tell you we don't want to be divided
what we want the common denominator that
i found in every single interview is we
want to be validated
we want to be understood
i've done over
35 000 interviews in my career
and
as soon as that camera shuts off
everyone always turns to me and
inevitably in their own way asks this
question
was that okay
i heard it from president bush
i heard it from president obama
i've heard it from heroes and from
housewives i've heard it from victims
and perpetrators of crimes i even heard
it from beyonce and all of her beyonce
ness
she finishes performing hands me the
microphone and says was that okay
friends and family yours enemies
strangers in every argument in every
encounter every exchange i will tell you
they all want to know one thing
was that okay
did you hear me
do you see me
did what i say mean anything to you
and even though this is the college
where facebook was born
my hope is that you will try to go out
and have more face-to-face conversations
with people you may disagree with
[Applause]
that you'll have
the the courage
to look them in the eye and hear their
point of view
and
help make sure that the speed and
distance
and anonymity of our world doesn't cause
us to lose our ability to stand in
somebody else's shoes
and recognize all that we share as a
people this is imperative for you as an
individual and for our success as a
nation what about something that you
feel like you've personally achieved or
overcome is there something that you are
especially proud of yourself for yeah
i'm
especially proud of myself for not uh
living in the world of comparisons you
know
uh years ago when i pulled out that
wagon of fat i was actually comparing
myself to everybody else or what i
thought you're supposed to look like or
what size you're supposed to be so i've
now reached the point where i'm really
okay
exactly where i am and that's you know
it's taken me a lifetime practically to
figure that out and being okay exactly
where you are because preparing is a
date it's so hard because we are in the
world of insta comparison you know and
so
the real spiritual practice is to like
live from within and not let the world
divine who you are but you
do that for yourself that's that's the
hardest work you um are now the ceo of
your company you're the owner and the
ceo and you've got thousands of people
working for you yeah and as a ceo do you
have to say no to people all the time
and is that hard to do uh you get other
people who say no that no okay
um saying no is hard that is one of the
big big
lessons life lessons for me i i i grew
up obviously girl
raised in the south women need to please
wanting to please everybody so it took
me a long time to get that lesson of
only saying yes to what you intend to
say yes to and and so uh i tried to do
all of my business decisions and
personal decisions based upon
my intention many of you
as i have been as i am are where you are
in your life
based upon what you believe and it's not
just what you think you believe on the
surface it's also your shadow beliefs
that are holding you back from moving
into the life that you believe
you deserve what i know is if you're not
looking at the shadows if you're not
looking at what is subconsciously
running through the tape in your mind
telling yourself you're not good enough
you're not worthy enough you're not
smart enough you're not enough
which is a tape that's playing for a lot
of people if you're not conscious of
that
then you end up acting out of that
belief system and not out of what you
know to be the truest or want to be the
truest for yourself but you don't become
what you want because so much of wanting
is about
living in the space of what you don't
have that's why jim carrey's story is so
powerful because he started to act as
though he already had it he would go up
to mulholland drive he would drive away
sink thinking i already have those
things i just haven't accessed them as
yet i believe those things are going to
come to me and i'm going to act like
they are so i'm going to move forward in
my life in order to draw that to myself
in such a way that my actions are in
alignment with what i say i believe
so if you start to think about that
really why are you where you are in your
life the choices that you have made
have been because of what you believe to
be true for yourself the biggest
transformation for me was living my life
with intention you know what i know i
live by this law of that's the third law
of motion physics which you put out is
coming back but before you even put it
out you have an intention and so to have
a clarity of intention about what you
actually want to do and why you want to
do it is the most important thing and
then to just set that vision and have
every step you make move you in the
direction of that vision it doesn't mean
that every day it's going to happen some
days you're off track like i intended to
work out 45 minutes i only got in 37
this morning well that's better than two
it's better than zero and that's that's
that's that's what i said okay at least
you got some movement in and i'll go
back and i'll make up the other eight
later but
i think you just made it up
actually as i was walking i think i
think this is gonna be eight minutes i'm
gonna make it up so uh it's it's about
it's daily renewal it's not one big
gigantic goal it's every day coming back
giving yourself the opportunity to get
it right because that's what every
sunrise means it's oh gosh it's another
chance to get it right it is yeah allow
me to have an intent and purpose
intent is everything there has to be
some way
that this darkness can be banished with
light
says the man whose little boy
was massacred on just an ordinary friday
in december
so whether you call it
soul or spirit or higher self
intelligence
there is i know this there's a light
inside each of you
all of us
that illuminates your very human
beingness if you let it
and as a young girl from rural
mississippi i learned long ago that
being myself was much easier than
pretending to be barbara walters
although when i first started because i
had barbara in my head i would try to
sit like barbara talk like bob removed
like barbara and then one night i was on
the news reading the news and i called
canada kanada and uh
that was the end of me being barbara i
cracked myself up on tv
couldn't stop laughing and my real
personality came through and i figured
out oh gee i can be a much better oprah
than i could be a pretend barbara i have
a very big life
and so people with big lives can do big
things and so i started to think about
what was the best christmas i ever had
in my life i grew up poor uh on welfare
with my mother for part of my life
and i remember that the best christmas
of my life was when i was 12 years old
and
my mother had said
we're not going to have christmas
because we can't afford it
and my feeling at the time was okay well
so that runs that's santa claus bit
i was 12 that's when i realized there
was no santa claus because now he ain't
coming because we're poor
and uh
i remember feeling like
it's gonna be really hard on christmas
morning to go outside
everybody had you know you go outside
with your toys what am i gonna do when
everybody else is outside
that's what i thought what am i going to
do when everybody else is outside and
what am i going to do when i have to go
back to class and say i got nothing so
that's what i was mostly worried about
and then some nuns showed up
some three nuns came to our house and
they gave me a doll and they bought us
food and we had our christmas that was
the best christmas of my life because
somebody remembered and i wasn't going
to have to be
the kid that said i got nothing so i
wanted to be able to create that same
feeling
for
children who had nothing
so i decided to go to south africa
originally i wanted to do a million kids
because i thought we can do a million
kids
and then just realize with i only had uh
four weeks vacation so in four weeks i
could not reach a million kids because i
didn't want to just write a check
send a donation i wanted to be able to
look in each kid's face and say to that
child somebody remembered you and so
that's what i did with my life this
christmas i took 41 people from here
hired another 50 people over there and
we were traveling caravan from one
village to the next we did 2 000 kids a
day
we had um
parties for children who were uh orphans
and it was singularly i will tell you i
could weep thinking about it the
singularly the best experience of my
life
the singularly best experience of my
life the first day in africa where we
had um
three 280 kids in a room and every
single one of those kids had lost a
parent
every single one of those children they
were age 3
to 17 in that room and my team that
you're talking about i have the greatest
team in the world my team in here in the
united states had been in contact with
the orphanages so that by the time we
got there
we had a present with every child's name
on it
i had um
this summer
every black doll manufacturer in the
country had sent me dolls because i
these girls had never seen black dolls
and so it was my mission to do for them
what the nuns had done for me was to let
the african girls see a black doll so i
wanted every girl to have a black doll i
wanted every boy to have soccer balls we
bought radios we bought clothes and the
most important thing is we had their
names on every box for every child
and i called up the children one by one
and when those children
you know received their gifts and then
waited for the next child to receive
their gifts and said
i said nobody can open their presents
until everybody can open their presents
and on the count of three when i counted
the three and those children open their
presents was the single greatest moment
of my life
and i share that with you
i share that with you
because that's what i can do i can be i
have a big life so i can take 50 000
presents and do that over and over and
over again to orphanage orphanage but
what i felt in that room for those from
those kids
is a lot of what you're talking about
and what you're talking about and what
you see in the faces those women when
you look into the eyes of someone
and you give them a gift whether that be
a physical gift or it'd be a gift from
your
spiritual self from your presence from
the essence of you and you see the light
you see the joy what i felt in that room
was not just that i was remembered that
that the child felt that i was
remembered but you felt a sense of hope
a sense of validation a sense of
validation that somebody cared about me
and i will tell you that
of all the years and shows that i have
done
and every theme for every show that i've
done
the single common denominator
denominator that i found that every
human being is looking for is validation
every single person needs to know
wants to feel that they matter
that they matter and what happened in
that room that was the greatest day of
my life i knew that those children knew
in that moment that they mattered that
they mattered and so i encourage you
it's exciting to be able to write a
check
it's even more exciting to be able to
touch one life
to be able to do that for one person
it's like cynthia was saying when you
can do that for one person when you can
do that you will know that your life has
meaning and i will tell you when i left
that place my my friend gail and i were
there and we were all boohoo and we're
like booming with the children oh my god
and gail was saying what is it what is
it we're so full as gail said to me she
said you know as big as your show is as
big as your show is what happened in
that room seemed bigger
what happened in that room sing bigger
and that is true that is true for me who
has this big life in a television show
and i'm telling you for everybody here
extending yourself beyond your world
your kids your family your stuff and
reaching out to somebody who is not like
you somebody who is like you who is
indeed if you are feeling depressed or
you are feeling down or you're feeling
like things aren't going the way you
want them to go in your life the way you
turn that around is to reach outside of
yourself i don't make resolutions
anymore i have a word so at my dinner
table we all go around the table and we
say what's your word for this year okay
and my word is purpose
my word for this year is purpose because
when i look back on my you know how you
can't even figure out what you did in a
year because your life's so full yeah so
another now i just go back and i look
through my phone so i was doing that on
new year's eve looking through the phone
at all the pictures all the stuff you've
done and i did a lot of things but i
didn't do a lot of things on purpose
with intentional purpose so my thing
this year is don't do anything unless
you have an intention and a purpose
behind it you wish yourself they call
her auntie gayle and me mamo i said you
all wish to have a friend like auntie
gayle
you want to have a friend
who wants
the most the best and the highest for
you i have never seen a person like gail
i've never
yeah
you know everybody especially if you uh
are on the rise in your career and you
have had certain friends and they all
act like they're happy for you but not
everybody's happy for you and every now
and then you can hear just a teeny bit
of jealousy you can hear it you can
sense it i've never had a moment's
jealousy from gail in you know the 30
odd years of her friendship except for
the one time
i was on stage dancing with tina turner
you know in all of the years of doing
the oprah show
there were many days that i sat in my
chair across from one or two or five or
six or seven people and i would be
so
frustrated
because
i just wanted to shake people sometimes
and say
why
didn't you pay attention to your life
i said on the show probably the
producers tell me that they counted 33
times but i know i thought it at least a
thousand times i would say listening to
your life
as it whispers to you first so that it
does not have to knock you upside the
head with a brick or come crashing down
on you as a brick wall
is
one of the greatest principles of life
because
there are many things that happen in
life that are beyond our control natural
disasters
death
unexplained events but there are also
many many many things in life which we
can control and become out of control
because you're just not paying attention
you are sleepwalking through your life
and i have seen this so many times on
the show i wanted to take the guests and
go would you just pay attention so this
is what i've learned and how i've
explained it to myself
life whispers to you all the time your
life is speaking to you all around from
the time you wake up in the morning
and every single experience that's
coming into
your
personal space
into your physical space all of those
experiences are speaking to you they're
telling you something about your life
and about your circumstances it whispers
and if you don't get the whisper the
whisper gets louder if you don't get the
whisper when it gets louder it gets i
call it like a little pebble like a
little thump upside your head when i was
a kid if i was doing something my
grandmother didn't like she'd just turn
around and thump me she wouldn't even
look at me she'd just give me a thump
and i'd know that's that's my cue to
stop it or you we're gonna get worse
the whisper is the message the pebble or
the thump upside the head usually it's
gone into a problem you don't pay
attention to the problem the problem
becomes a brick upside your head the
brick upside your head is a crisis you
don't pay attention to the brick upside
your head the crisis turns into a
disaster and the whole house brick wall
comes falling down the angel network
i've been on the air for
a long time
but it was the angel network that
actually focused my internal gps it
helped me to decide that i wasn't just
gonna be on tv every day but that the
goal of my shows my interviews my
business my philanthropy all of it
whatever ventures i might pursue would
be to make clear
that
what
unites us
is ultimately
far more redeeming and compelling than
anything that separates me because what
it become clear to me and i want you to
know it isn't always clear in the
beginning because as i said i've been on
television since i was 19 years old
but around 94 i got really clear so
don't expect the clarity to come all at
once to know your purpose right away
but what became clear to me was that i
was here
on earth to use television and not be
used by it
to use television to illuminate the
transcendent power
of our better angels
so
this angel network it didn't just change
the lives of those who were helped but
the lives of those who also did the
helping
it reminded us that no matter who we are
or what we look like or what we may
believe it is both possible
and more importantly it becomes powerful
to come together in common purpose and
common effort developing shows that
speak uh
to
the humanity of people in a way that
makes them want to
live better and do better
and um
that exalts their
their their victories and lets them know
that they are important and meaningful
in the world you know i would have to
say
that
every day david that show was such a it
was like therapy for me kind of like now
every day this show
was
i paid attention so i've never been to a
therapist but i i i paid attention all
those days on the show and i made
therapy acceptable for a lot of people
who thought uh they're not me not so
one of the things i started to get
uh around
mid to late no no mid to late 90s is
that every body that i had on the show
at the end of the show would say
something to me like
um
was that okay was that okay how was that
was that okay right at the end of the
interview
and i started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was um i i had gone and
done a show where i was in um
a prison i was interviewing a father
who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters and at the end of the
interview even behind bars he said to me
is that okay
how'd i do
and barack obama said it when he sat in
the chair the first time and
george bush said it beyonce said it at
the end of she taught me how to talk and
then said is that okay
so that's an acquired skill do you think
yes working thing but this is what i
learned
sitting in that chair for 25 years that
at the end of the day
whether you are
interviewing me or i get to interview
you whatever your profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships
every person that you encounter every
experience the person wants to know
was that okay
was that okay
and what i started to hear was that what
people are really saying is did you hear
me
did you hear me
and did what i say mean anything to you
you will find true success and happiness
if you have only one goal there really
is only one and that is this
to fulfill
the highest
most truthful
expression of yourself
as a human being
you want to max out your humanity
by using your energy to lift yourself up
your family and the people around you
theologian howard thurman said it best
he said don't ask yourself what the
world needs
ask yourself what makes you come alive
and then go do that
because what the world needs is people
who have come alive
the world needs
people like michael stahlzenberg from
fort lauderdale when michael was just
eight years old michael nearly died from
a bacterial infection that cost him both
of his hands and both of his feet
and in an instant this vibrant little
boy became a quadruple amputee
and his life
was changed forever
but in losing who he once was michael
discovered who he wanted to be
he refused to sit in that wheelchair all
day and feel sorry for himself so with
prosthetics he learned to walk
and run and play again
he joins his middle school lacrosse team
and last month when he learned that so
many victims of the boston marathon
bombing would become new amputees
michael decided to banish that darkness
with light
michael and his brother harris created
mikeysrun.com
to raise one million dollars for other
amputees
by the time harris runs the 2014 boston
marathon
more than a thousand miles away from
here these two young brothers
are bringing people together to support
this boston community the way their
community came together to support
michael
and when this 13 year old man was asked
about his fellow amputees he said this
first
they will be sad
they're losing something
they will never get back
and that's scary
i was scared
but they'll be okay
they just don't know that yet
we might not always know it
we might not always see it or hear it on
the news
or even feel it in our daily lives but i
have faith
that no matter what
class of twenty thousand
thousand thirteen
you will be okay
and you will make sure our country is
okay
i have faith because of that
nine-year-old girl who went out and
collected the change
i have faith because of david and
francine wheeler i have faith because of
michael and harris stolzenberg and i
have faith
because of you the network of angels
sitting here today one of them khadijah
williams who came to harvard four years
ago
khadijah had attended
12 schools in 12 years
living out of garbage bags
amongst pimps and prostitutes and drug
dealers
homeless
going into department stores walmart in
the morning to bathe herself so that she
wouldn't smell in front of her
classmates
and today she graduates as a member of
the harvard class
of 2013. for me colored girl negro child
growing up in mississippi
that one of the greatest gifts i was
ever afforded was not to have been put
in a segregated school system
had i been put in a segregated school
and taught in a segregated school system
that said you're less than because
you're a woman and you're less than
because you're a colored woman
i probably wouldn't be here today i
would have had to then overcome that
belief that conditioning of a belief but
because
i was raised by a grandmother
who
raised me in the church
and
i went to church
sunday school
lived in the church
and i would sit there
second pew
on the right
third row
every sunday
just
taking it all in and i would listen to
the stories listen to the bible stories
and i would hear
that through god all things are possible
i would hear the story of jesus talking
about
if you have the faith of a mustard seed
and you know as many years later that i
actually
saw a mustard seed i could not believe
what a mustard seed actually looked like
have you ever seen a mustard seed here i
have some here
i want to pull one out now jesus said if
you had the faith of a mustard seed you
could move mountains
and anything was possible now i heard
this as a kid and i really believed it
and so the question is what do you
believe
do you believe
that you are worthy
of happiness do you believe that
happiness success
abundance
comfort fulfillment peace
joy
love is a part of your birthright
is that what you believe
or do you believe something else because
you will
manifest
the life that you believe
i've always known that no matter what my
belief is i'm going to be all right why
because i have that faith of a mustard
seed actually a few mustard seeds
empowerment is authority
it is a sign permission slip to actually
seize the day
it's the process of getting stronger and
more confident and more engaged and to
be empowered is to move to the world
without any kind of fear or any kind of
apology and with these gifts comes an
even deeper privilege i believe and that
is the ability to take charge of your
own life to own yourself and claim your
rights and here's what i know for sure
that to whom much is given much is
expected
and i have been given so much
i've earned it
i've been blessed with it
but i've been given a lot
and that's why i've chosen to use my
life to lift other people up nobody's
journey is seamless or smooth we all
stumble we all have setbacks if things
go wrong you hit a dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying time to
change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me and as soon as you get the
lesson
you get to move on if you really get the
lesson you pass and you don't have to
repeat the class if you don't get the
lesson it shows up wearing another pair
of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work
and what i found is that difficulties
come when you don't pay attention to
life's whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me
what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend eckhart tolle
who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth
that's all about letting the awareness
of who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get is a half an hour you need
to focus on the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support and
gail and i got on a plane and flew to
south africa and the whole time i kept
asking that question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been
i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things
i built that school from the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power i have always known this
about celebrity
the real
power of being
somebody that somebody knows and i
really think that the only difference
between being famous and not is that
more people know your name
so the only difference
between understanding that
is understanding that what selma has
done what susan has done what anna has
done rebecca has done what jim has done
what i've done
you too can do
because true philanthropy comes from
living from the heart of yourself
and giving what you have been given
how will you do that
how will you use
your personality
the energy of your personality to serve
that which is your soul's calling
i know this for sure
any life
no matter how fantastic it is
how glorious it seems how much attention
you receive how much square footage you
have
any life and every life is enhanced by
the sharing and the giving and the
opening up of the heart space
your life gets better when you can find
a way to share it with someone else
so what we've done you can do the real
empowerment comes when every person
leaves this room
and makes a decision
makes a decision
maybe that decision is that you will
write a check and support some of the
wonderful organizations you've heard
here today
but the true decision is
how will you use yourself
how will you use everything that you
have been given
to serve that which is greater than
yourself
how will you use that to become
truly
authentically empowered
now
it is a beautiful thing to receive an
award and to be on the cover of variety
thank you very much
it's a beautiful thing
but the true reward is in the lives that
you are able to touch and the people who
you know you have impacted are you ready
to allow abundance and blessings people
can't figure out how i got to be so
successful
it is because i have lived in the space
of spirit my whole life my favorite
bible verse because i am christian uh is
acts
something
i used to note a number but this is an
axe y'all can google it
but it says
thank you 1728.
in god i live and move and have my being
i live and move and have my being and
you want to know why i am really so
successful i knew that at four years old
i knew that when my grandmother said you
better watch me now because one day you
have to learn how to wash these clothes
and hang them up like this so watch how
i hold these clothes pins in my mouth
[Applause]
and the reason i could do that is
because spirit
otherwise known as intuition
my instinct said
[Music]
that's not gonna be my life
so we all have that spiritual side and
this lesson tonight is about connecting
to it i believe that beneath the surface
of all physical problems is a spiritual
solution there is a spiritual solution
why because you are a spiritual being
having a human experience that's the
beginning of understanding spirituality
you are a spiritual being
having a human
experience i had a job until i could
figure out what it was really
what that gave my life its purpose and
meaning
and um i had gotten demoted in my job in
baltimore as an anchor woman because
as they hired me and then they decided i
was the wrong color
and i was the wrong size and i was the
wrong you know i had lots of problems
and they were trying to take me off the
air
and
i was making 22 000 a year i thought i
was in heaven because i was making my
age
and my dream at the time was gail and i
used to say can you imagine if you're 40
and you're making 40 000 would that be
it
so um
uh that was as big as my dream was just
to make my age
and then i did this they they put me on
a talk show one morning because um
they didn't know what to do with me
and and i was interviewing the carvel
ice cream man it was a local talk show
and
um
benny from um
benny who was mrs
chancellor's
uh butler or something on all my
children anyway my soap opera star who
wasn't the lead star remember benny
benny and the caravel ice cream men
that's how i cut my teeth and i finished
that show so it's not about the the
the stars themselves or whoever the
guests were but i felt like this is what
i'm supposed to do all these years have
been misplaced in news because i
couldn't relate to news i was a news
reporter and i'd be out on the stories
and i'd be crying with the people
and i felt that i was exploiting the
people with news i couldn't you know put
a microphone in people's face when they
were going through tragedies and stuff i
just was so emotional i was always
getting little notes from my boss about
cut that out you need to stop so but the
moment i did that talk show i felt like
oh
i can be myself
and that was august 14th 1978 and that
was the beginning of fulfilling the
calling and so since that time
since that time august 14th 1978 i've
never had a problem with energy now when
i was working in news i used to be
exhausted all the time because i just
exhausted all the time because i hated
it
and the reason i didn't quit is because
i'm not a quitter number one and cause
my father was like better not quit that
job you're making twenty two thousand
dollars a year
who's gonna play a black woman between
two thousand dollars a year you're never
gonna make it make that kind of money
again you better save half of it so
i i was reluctant to quit and think
about doing something else because i
thought okay
everybody wants to be an anchor woman at
the time that was like supposedly a big
deal being an anchor woman so i thought
okay i won't i'll just stay with this
until i can figure out what is the best
thing to do
and interestingly enough i was applying
for what i wanted to do
i felt like i needed to be able to talk
and at the time the only thing was
available was um
was uh like good morning america or the
today show so i called up this agent and
i asked if he would accept my tape
because i wanted to be like a substitute
for brian gumbel and he said to me
there was only going to be one brian
gumbel and so
there wasn't going to be another one
that they weren't going to let another
black person on that show he said that
to me
and um interestingly enough he called me
last week because somebody else mentions
it they say he never said it but he did
say it and i said to him you know what
if you're ever told that you never
forget it if somebody ever says to you
if you were ever rejected in that way
you never ever ever forget it i said but
it's okay i did okay you did okay
it's all right but the answer to your
question is
if you can find what is your passion if
you find what you love you never get
tired or if you do get tired you you're
fueled by the energy of your work so i
know that i'm doing exactly what i'm
supposed to be doing at this time
i also know that what the the show can
do
in terms of being
a voice and changing the world it's just
the beginning of what this show can do
it's fun to do things like this
but uh and it's necessary to do things
like this in order to be able to do the
bigger grander things to change what
happens to to the face of children in
africa for example what happens to
education with kids in in this country
so i believe that um
that what has happened to me is really
the beginning
of the greater passion to come
but if you find out what you're supposed
to do and you know what you're supposed
to do by how it feels
you know people wait on the voice of god
to be some the moses in burning bush i
think that was only bible talk
you know because he doesn't come to
burning bushes for people he comes
through your heart
he speaks through your heart through
your feelings and so you know what if
you're doing the right thing if it feels
like it's right to you and when you hit
the thing that feels right when you know
it's the right thing you would you know
it's right because it gives you your
juice and you know it's right because
you would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue
that's how you know you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing how do i
define success
let me tell you money's pretty nice
i'm not going to stand up here and tell
you that it's not about money because
money is very nice
i like money
it's good for buying things
[Applause]
but having a lot of money does not
automatically
make you a successful person
what you want
is money
and
meaning you want your work to be
meaningful
because meaning is what brings the real
richness to your life
what you really want
is to be surrounded by people you trust
and treasure and by people who cherish
you
that's when you're really rich i'm
content i'm not just relaxed i'm content
because i know a lot of rich people who
are not happy
but i am not one of them
but when you're i am one of the happiest
rich people you are ever going to see
when you're trying to just
when you're trying to get away from it
all and just get away from everything
you just relax at one of your homes or
yes i rely well and also it doesn't take
a lot for me to relax time to time you
may stumble
fall you will for sure count on this
no doubt
you will have questions
and you will have doubts about your path
but i know this if you're willing to
listen
to be guided by that still small voice
that is the gps within yourself
to find out what makes you come alive
you will be more than okay
you will be
happy
you will be successful
and you will make a difference in the
world if you want more top 10 videos
they're not on this channel anymore i
have a dedicated channel just for it go
check it out the link is right there
next to me continue to believe and i'll
see you there